Ça va ? vous êtes remis des révélations du dernier épisode ?
Moi pas !
*rires*
C'est parti pour le 7ème épisode
Là c'est directement la suite
eeeeuuuuuuhhh ...
je pense qu'on va revenir dans le présent du coup après cette ellipse
yes !
yes yes yes !
du coup il m'a pas bouffé, ça va...
lève toi petit
Je contrôle son bras, non ?
*rire* Je me suis enflammé !
Réveille-toi petit !
Voilà, secoue-moi Trico
Faut me réveiller
Yes
On s'en va d'ici ?
Il a réussi à lutter contre les ondes
Tu me reposes
Ah j'suis pas réveillé hein ?
J'suis pas réveillé
Sois patient mon grand, désolé !
Ah, il est tout triste...
T'as envie hein, que je revienne à moi-même ?
Vas-y, avance !
*rires*
J'suis un steak haché mon gars
Tu me mets au soleil pour que ça me réveille ?
C'est pas con !
Ah c'est triste...
C'est triste mon gars !
Réveille-toi, tu rends triste Trico !
Putain il a plus d'idées, il sait plus quoi faire Trico
Ca me met trop mal !
Ah dans de l'eau !
Malin ça !
C'est des petits détails trop bien faits
que par exemple il met sa patte dans l'eau
avant de me mettre dedans
pour vérifier qu'elle est pas trop froide ou pas trop chaude.
Je dis ça parce que mon chat fait pareil !
On se réveille
Re-bonjour Trico !
Comment ça va mon grand ?
Je te monte dessus direct !
Ah bah oui t'es content !
Aïe aïe, attention !
Oh, putain quel bon début de vidéo !
L'inverse du début de
de, du début du 6ème épisode.
Vous avez vu, là y a Trico,
il nous câline, il est tout content
On est bien là !
On est venu de là-bas il me semble...
J'espère qu'il n'y aura plus les ondes hein,
si tu redeviens méchant, heu...
Ca va pas le faire pour moi !
Attends peut-être...
si là-haut, attends
Si si si en fait !
Là, s'il se met du coup contre ça,
moi je peux aller là-haut !
Voilà !
Tu as vu,
tu te mets debout ?
Vas-y, tu as vu !
Ah, yes
Ah ouais d'accord okay,
c'était choix calculé,
c'est pour ça que t'as mis un petit peu de temps
J'aurais pu me faire embrocher par les trucs du dessus
Donc je passe de l'autre côté,
et puis il va y avoir un petit levier.
T'affoles, t'affoles pas il va y avoir un petit levier c'est sûr !
On va pouvoir t'ouvrir !
On finirait pas ce,
ce let's play sans toi Trico,
tu sais bien !
Ok, petite technique heu...
Easy, les mains de Squezzie échelle !
Voilà, regarde !
Qu'est-ce que je t'avais dit ?
Tu vois faut qu'on s'écoute,
faut qu'on communique !
*rires*
Allez let's go !
Avançons
Ouh, c'est beau ça !
Ca ressemble à une petite mine,
on est dans une petite mine, clairement
On va aller voir, ce qui s'y cache
Alors là tu passes pas Trico, clairement mec
*rires*
J'aimerais bien trouver un petit heu...
Un petit baril pour te donner à manger !
Même si on dirait que les ondes qui t'ont rendu heu,
Vilain ils t'ont plus heu, donné de l'énergie qu'autre chose en fait !
Trico, sans mytho, tu veux pas pousser cette porte ?
Tu la pousses vite fait ?
Ah mais non, c'est peut-être moi, je dois faire le tour en fait
Non mais non, parce qu'il n'y a pas d'accès ici vers la droite...
Peut-être s'il met sa tête...
Je peux accéder à un truc en hauteur ?
Ah ,
Ahhhh, c'est là !
Tu peux rentrer ta tête là-dedans ou pas ?
Dis-moi Trico, fais mon rêver !
*bruit sourd*
Oh !
Il se passe un truc,
il est en train de ramper !
C'est très bien ça !
Faut que je m'aide de ta tête hein, pour monter...
Ouais, ouais c'est ça !
Ouais, regarde je vais juste m'aider de ta tête mon gars !
Pour atteindre le, la barre
Ou là-bas directement !
Attends, on va y arriver
On va y arriver bouge pas, bouge pas, bouge pas !
Yes !
Merci Trico !
P'tain je pensais vraiment que...
j'pensais vraiment pas qu'il pouvait venir comme ça !
Du coup il nous a mis très très bien !
Ah !
C'est des cailloux ça
Alors...
Du coup ici on est de l'autre côté des portes...
On va pouvoir lui ouvrir et puis on va continuer vers là-bas je pense, ouais !
Je t'ouvre mon grand !
Voilà !
Allez il va venir, il va comprendre tout seul comme un grand
Ici qu'est-ce qu'on a ?
Ohhh...
La lumière au bout...
Okay
Pourquoi tu viens pas ?
Tu peux ramper regarde
Voilà, accroupis-toi !
*rires*
Le pauvre,
Ca doit être tellement oppressant !
Allez ramène-toi !
Je vais t'ouvrir mon gars !
Je vais t'ouvrir tu seras bien !
Allez viens !
Je t'ai ouvert...
Vas-y, viens vite...
Yes
T'es coincé ?
Mais non, t'es pas coincé ?
Si je t'ai fait mettre ta tête là,
c'est quand même pour une raison, non ?
Ah putain ouais merde, du coup là c'est...
Ahhh !
*bruits d'effondrement*
Oh merde !
Encore un éboulement ?
Rho putain hé c'est normal,
décidément on arrête pas d'être séparé !
J'aimerais bien qu'on le voit vieux du coup,
Parce que la, le...
Quand il raconte l'histoire il a une voix d'homme et tout donc je pense ça doit être...
10 ans plus tard minimum
J'aimerais bien voir sa tête 10 ans plus tard...
J'espère qu'on verra...
Heu...
Okay...
Ah !
Ah ouais, Trico t'es mal, putain !
Bon écoute je peux que passer vers là pour sortir...
Est-ce que je vais pouvoir t'aider à sortir de là ?
Heu... T'es complètement enseveli mon grand...
T'es com...
Mais je vais devoir te monter dessus pour accéder à la sortie
Putain merde,
Faut que je trouve un moyen de l'aider là,
Comment je peux faire ?
Il est complètement sous les décombres...
Whoua...
Ok attends faut que je me dépêche...
Faut que je me dépêche parce que ça doit appuyer sur ses poumons,
et il pourra plus respirer bientôt...
Hé Trico on se réveille mon grand, on se réveille !
Au début de l'épisode c'est toi qui me réveiller maintenant c'est moi qui doit heu...
Te réveiller !
*rires*
On va vraiment faire les choses à tour de rôles,
c'est ça qu'est bon !
On va passer par ce petit trou là...
Qu'est-ce qu'on a de l'autre côté, de la grosse lumière encore ?
Heu...
Ouais mais là mec j'peux pas l'aider quoi !
J'peux vraiment pas l'aider !
Bah écoute je vais sortir, on va voir si on peut...
Aller chercher de l'aide ?
Le truc improbable, qui n'arrivera jamais dans ce jeu...
On est deux et tout le monde et contre nous...
Oh putain y a une porte, ça c'est...
Ca ça sent le garde...
Y a un javelot, je vais écouter vos conseils :
Vous m'aviez dit qu'on pouvait prendre les javelots...
Vous m'avez menti,
vous m'avez menti on peut pas les prendre !
*rires*
L'idée était bonne mais on peut pas, putain...
Ohhh !
What the fuck ?!
Heu je fais comment là ?
Ah ?
Trico ça le vénère si j'les, si je les rapproche ?
Je crois qu'il est en train de, de sortir...
Who, il fait quoi là ?
Il arrive ?
Whoooo !
Badass Trico !
P'tain tu les sens ces putains d'armures, tu viens direct !
Tu rappliques direct !
Hé bim !
Alors grosse merde, ça fait moins le kéké !
Ah j'peux lui arr...
Oh !
On n'avait jamais fait ça !
*rires*
Ca va,
on est bon, on peut continuer notre route !
Et faire une chute !
Allez on va aller vers là-bas Trico !
Follow-me !
Heu ouais, ça c'est une manière de descendre mais pour toi mon gars
*rires*
C'est clairement pas moi qui vais descendre comme ça...
Oh putain ça sent la...
Ca sent le total one point 2ème édition !
Voilà, il pousse sa petite gueulante,
Allez on descends !
Accroche-toi gamin !
Okay...
Je vois où tu veux en venir,
On va aller la-dessus et ça va se péter la gueule,
Et on va devoir finir à mort...
Voilà !
Oh putain...
*craquements*
Ouais !
Ouais, ouais, ouais !
Ouais
Faut courir là !
*craquements*
Et y a les miroirs au bout !
Il va se bloquer parce qu'il y a les miroirs au bout !
Très bien, donc tu veux pas continuer...
P'tain les miroirs ils sont loin là, tu peux pas faire un effort, nan ?
Il s'avance un petit peu...
Hein hein...
C'est le jour où Trico n'a plus peur des miroirs ?
Ou pas ?
Oh, il s'approche près !
Non, il a toujours peur...
Je vais y aller mon grand
C'est pas grave...
Bon ça, c'est plus grave, du coup !
Bon faut que je saute du coup en face...
Ou juste en bas ?
Juste en bas je suppose...
Ouais !
Faut remonter ?
Bah ok,
Faut monter à ça je suppose...
Oh ça va être un coup à base de gardes et Trico ne pourra pas nous aider, ou...
Mais non !
Non, faut que j'arrête à vouloir gagner du temps !
Ok, on est contre le mur donc il faut bien aller là-bas,
et contourner !
Hum hum !
Pourquoi il veut qu'on se suspende ?
On est très bien heu, pas suspendu !
Okay...
Bon on est en train de contourner tout le bâtiment...
Heu j'aimerais pas qu'il y ait une petite armure par ici...
Hein, si vous voyez ce que je veux dire,
Ca me ferait un peu chier...
Mais c'est quoi ce bâtiment, on dirait qu'il contient quelque chose de spécial,
Vous avez vu la texture ?
On n'avait jamais vu un bâtiment avec une texture comme ça dans mes souvenirs...
Vous avez vu, il y a des espèces d'inscriptions contre le mur...
Très bizarre ce bâtiment, je suis persuadé qu'il contient heu...
Soit un truc spécial, soit un max de gardes...
Ou alors les deux !
Okay...
On monte maintenant...
On gagne en hauteur, en verticalité...
Comme on dit !
Ah !
Une grille...
Oh, regardez !
Peut-être qu'on a trouvé le truc spécial,
C'est quoi ça ?
Hé, mais est-ce que c'est pas,
Ca va pas être le retour du miroir là, hein ?
Faut qu'on trouve un truc et qu'on le foute dedans, c'est ça ?
Donc là je pense qu'on est remonté à hauteur de Trico...
On va arriver de l'autre côté,
On va pouvoir pousser les, les vilaines vitres en forme d'oeil !
Ouais, on va pas tarder à voir Trico...
Voilà, il est là-bas !
Ah il est faché, putain !
Ici y a rien, non...
Ah y a une porte mec à gauche,
Heu c'est pas très beau...
Y a deux portes là !
Ca va arriver...
Ca va arriver sur lui...
Il doit y avoir un détecteur, un truc et...
Je vais avoir très peu de temps pour péter les...
Les miroirs !
Ok, le premier c'est bon...
Oh merde !
Pourquoi, pourquoi j'ai pris grave cher de loin comme ça ?
Laissez-moi !
Whouaa, ils m'envoient tellement de sorts !
Hiiii !
Non !
J'peux rien faire, j'suis bloqué !
J'peux rien faire, j'reçois trop de sorts les gars,
Je, je peux pas m'en sortir,
Je peux rien faire, ils vont me choper...
Soit c'est un bug, soit c'est...
Attends mais c'est un chef ça !
Whouaa !
Ils vont réussir à m'emmener je pense...
Est-ce que... Trico faut que tu battes ta peur du miroir sinon je suis foutu !
Trico ?
Oh !
Ca y est...
Il a fait face à sa peur mec...
Il va voler ?
Ouille !
Okay...
T'as volé mon grand, je suis fière de toi !
Petit Trico grandi tellement !
C'est ouf !
Oh putain !
J'arrive, j'arrive, le problème c'est que tu vois c'est pas très stable...
C'est bon, le levier est juste là...
Okay...
Hop là !
*bruits d'effondrement*
C'est bon il s'en sort...
Ah j'peux pas bouger par contre !
C'est bon...
Ah !
Putain va falloir que je redescende pour activer l'autre levier !
Rho putain...
Rho comment il me regarde c'est horrible...
C'est pour ça que ça c'était là depuis le début...
J'arrive mon grand, tient le coup, t'auras de la bouffe apr...
-près...
La queue...
La queue sur la main...
Okay c'est bon...
J'arrive tient le coup, tient le coup j'arrive, désolé !
Il perd des plumes en plus...
Ca le stresse, il est tout stressé il perd des plumes
Nous quand on est stressé on perd des cheveux lui il perd des plumes mon gars...
Okay, allez vas-y...
Allez allez, cette fois c'est la bonne...
J'suis là j'suis là, me crie pas dessus !
C'est bon c'est bon c'est bon!
On est bon cette fois ?
Rha putain, mais c'est dingue !
Ah c'est bon !
Nickel !
*rires*
Il revient mettre...
Ah je vais te sauter dans la bouche ?
Tu me laisses pas tomber ?
Merci mon pote !
Bravo Trico !
Merci mon grand...
Ah...
C'est pas grave, on va...
"Donc c'est bien, nous étions si proches", je pense qu'il parle donc de la tour qu'est,
Qu'était là-bas et qui est très heu... Spécial !
Heu...
Y avait même, vous avez vu cet espèce de truc qu'on a vu devant la porte,
On sait pas toujours pas ce que c'est, quoi...
Bon bah écoute Trico, hein..
La vie continue...
On reprend notre route...
Tu fais quoi, tu marches à reculons ?
Mais qu'est-ce tu fous ?
Retourne-toi...
*rires*
Qu'est-ce qu'il fout ?
Alors...
On atterrie ici...
Bah Trico je vais, je vais avoir besoin de toi !
Nice !
On n'a pas grand chose à faire ici hein Trico...
Très bien...
Sur le toit tu peux tenir toi ou pas ?
Ouais, je sais pas si c'était une bonne idée de tenter le toit...
Si ?
Ok très bien...
Putain c'est terrible, c'est frustrant parce qu'on fait que gagner en hauteur et de perdre en hauteur et de gagner en hauteur et de perdre en hauteur...
Ca fout les boules...
Ah bah si si, je pense avoir trouvé où il faut descendre Trico,
Faut descendre juste là en bas en fait, ouais vas-y tu l'as vu !
Ah si là-haut regarde pour toi, juste là-haut j'avais pas vu !
Yep...
Merci Trico !
On est bien ?
Alors on va y aller...
Ouf putain de merde, ok donc...
Nouveau bâtiment...
Avec une armure... Avec des armures !
Putain, d'entrée de jeu quoi !
Si, si je chope moi-même mec je vais finir en lambeaux...
Et je parle de la voiture ! (Lambo)
Excellent !
Okay, t'as sauté !
Hé bah vas-y, tu sais ce qui te restes à faire hein !
Il s'est carrément tout fait en deux-deux !
Donc je vais, je vais d'avance péter le truc qu'il y a là-bas...
Saloperie de miroirs !
Saloperie !
What the fuck ?
C'est particulier, il y a deux chaînes derrière,
Qu'est-ce que c'est que ça ?
Oulà...
Non si c'est bon...
Okay je vais pousser...
Oh !
On va retrouver le miroir regardez !
Y a ces espèces de portes à casser avec le miroir qu'il y avait au début du jeu...
A moins que...
Bon, à mon avis ces chaînes ne sont pas là pour rien,
Quoiqu'elles mènent nulle part...
Donc je pense qu'il y a le petit escalier derrière à gauche qu'on va devoir prendre...
Pour aller quelque part...
Allez hop !
Allons-y... Ah bah il y a un levier juste là tient c'est parfait !
Qu'est ce que ça fait, ça va...
Lever le pont ?
Le baisser !
Et bah voilà !
Parfait, on apprécie ça !
Qu'est-ce qu'il y a ?
Oh putain !
Rho putain ça va être la fight...
*rugissements*
Oh putain...
En plus lui il a une armure et tout...
Ouh, combat !
Je refais le levier !
Y a que le méchant qui est sur la partie du pont qui se baisse...
Regarde-moi ça, il va bien dégager ce con !
Lache Trico !
Roh putain il a chopé Trico...
Putain...
Sérieux, comment je fais moi ?
Je me laisse tomber ?
Ouais je pense que c'est ça, je vais tomber sur Trico vas-y...
Whouaaa !
Désolé Trico je te dérange en plein combat...
Là-bas y a un truc à faire, y a un levier, c'est parti !
Mais what the fuck ?
Putain de saloperie, putain de saloperie quoi...
Ok, ok j'ai immédiatement compris ce qu'il faut faire..
Faut prendre la queue de ce gros bâtard et la, l'amené vers ici !
Mais comment je peux faire ?
Ah ok de l'autre côté il y a la même porte, j'ai compris !
Putain !
Vas-y laissez-moi passer, laisse-moi passer maintenant !
On va passer, vous m'avez gonflé !
Laissez-moi passer, s'il-vous-plaît !
Hé là, les deux titans qui se battent !
J'aimerais passer !
Allez on n'a pas tout notre temps, dépêche-toi !
Ok c'est bon !
C'est là que je dois lui prendre sa queue et,
Je te jure qu'il va regretter d'avoir une queue mon pote,
Il va regretter !
Mais vraiment !
Et attention dans ta queue !
Oh tu vas morfler mon pote...
Oh il a du douiller...
Oh merde, il est sur moi maintenant !
Vous allez pas retomber quand même ?
Oh merde Trico il ne s'est pas relevé là en bas !
Heu, qu'est-ce que je dois faire maintenant ?
Oh un peu limite, là ok je me suis rattrapé,
Y a une chaîne, j'ai vu qu'il y a une chaîne qui pendait...
Voilà, il me la met bien en évidence, elle mène au gardien je suppose...
Non, c'est quoi ça ?
Un truc à pousser qui va tomber sur l'autre, okay !
Putain les amis là je suis en total, total stress c'est un truc de malade...
Okay je l'ai, c'est bon !
Whouaa !
Putain elle est super longue en plus, allez go !
Vas-y monte monte monte, on y est !
Trico tiens le coup mon grand !
Tiens le coup tient le coup, je vais, j'ose même pas regarder j'ai même pas envie de voir dans que état il est...
Je vais te donner heu... De la bouffe après !
C'est promis !
C'est promis c'est promis c'est promis, c'est une sale journée pour toi,
Ca arrive, on en connaît tous des comme ça heu...
Comment je fais là ?
Faut que je pousse ça ?
Putain mais ça doit être super lourd...
C'est bon !
Allez donne tout l'élan que tu peux là...
Pour que ça tombe bien vite dessus !
Tient !
Merde, c'est pas fini !
Ah, là on l'a explosé quoi !
Attends on dirait que c'est tombé sur Trico...
Non
Tu te retires ca y est, t'en as eu assez ?
Il lui manque une corne...
Ok Trico, est-ce que Trico va bien, est-ce que Trico va bien ?
Oh merde...
Oh merde, non j'ai mal visé, j'ai mal visé,
Tu vas tomber, fais pas, t'es proche du vide gamin !
Trico ça va ?
Trico mon grand, ça va ?
Fais un petit signe de vie...
Hein ?
Putain !
Putain...
Ca va ?
Oh qu'est-ce que tu fais ?
Tu vomis ?
*rires*
C'est le miroir mec !
T'avais avalé le miroir ?
Mais qu'est-ce que c'est que ça Trico ?
C'est des manières ?
Ca va aller...
Non je sais que ça va pas activer ton pouvoir, t'es trop claqué mais...
Je vais t'amener très vite à bouffer, t'en fais pas !
Dans le prochain épisode mes amis, j'espère que cet épisode vous a plu,
N'hésitez-pas à l'aimer si c'est le cas, c'était génial ce combat enfin,
Enfin ils se battent quoi, on n'arrêtait pas le croiser mais il n'y avait jamais Trico qui était là,
On a été tout le temps séparé et là enfin on a eu une vraie baston,
Le problème c'est qu'il a l'air plus entraîné, en plus il a une armure donc il...
Ah le fdp !
Hé bah je vous dit à très vite pour un prochain épisode,
Portez-vous bien, tchao tout le monde,
Peace !